[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
les points forts de la piste c'est avant
tout une liste plaisir oise sans
étiquette avec une majorité de personnes
investies dans le monde citoyens dans le
monde associatif
nous vivons nous aimons notre ville nous
y sommes engagés de longue date et nous
souhaitons effectivement un changement
positif sur différents aspects que ça
soit la santé la solidarité ou
l'écologie et nous sommes tous engagés
sur ce combat commun au delà des trois
aspects effectivement écologie
solidarité santé il en est un qui sort
du lot c'est en particulier la santé
nous souhaitons investir au nom de la
ville sur une maison médicale
pluridisciplinaire de façon à faciliter
la réinstallation durable de médecins
généralistes et de praticiens sur le sol
plaisir oies au nom de la ville avec la
lille et en leur apportant des services
clients leur de façon à ce qu'ils
puissent venir s'installer de manière
durable au service des chanaux la
première décision c'est surtout d'aller
au contact au contact des agents au
contact des associés sur en contact des
différents partenaires de la ville pour
ensemble bâtir un meilleur dialogue de
confiance aller au contact des quartiers
mais aussi pour mettre en place
rapidement les conseils de quartier et
elle devrait décider ensemble à ce que
va devenir l'avenir de noter en matière
d'écologie de pistes cyclables en
matière de transition énergétique de
santé et surtout de solidarité envers
nos jeunes et nos seniors
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]